Mình nhớ mới làm người đã thiệt mạng sau khi một phà trở hàng chăm hành khách và thuyền viên,
bị chiếm ngoài hơn miền Nam Philippines vào giận sáng ngày 20 x 30.
Cô thề thêu lực gượng bảo vệ bởi biển Philippines,
phà MVTUES SAA, KUSTIBA, Gặp Nạn vào khoảng 1 giờ nơi mì phút sáng,
khi đang chiến hành trình từ thành phố cảnh, chăm buồn ca, tới đảo vô lâu, thu tình xu lâu,
thời điểm sảy ra tay nạn, tàu trở bác chăm 3-2 hàng khách và 2-3 thuyền viên.
Năm trong giữa hàng bật cả châu Phi,
giới chiến cho biết đến nay đã cầu được 8-4 sáng người trong khi có ý nhất 20 tả người và mất tích.
Còn các phim kiếm cướng hạn ở đoạn trên khai trong điều kiện thời tiết và mặt biển tục đối thoại lời,
bởi sự thăm xa của lực gượng tuần duyên 2 quan, và các tổn dự,
một số tí thể đo được đưa vệ cả người xe, bê là thuộc phù tình và xí lăn.
Thống đất tình và xí lăn, mù chiếp hả tà màn cho biết,
phần lớn những người xong só trình thành trạch ord định,
săm một số hành khách lơ tuổi cần đoạn trong xói tế khẩn cấp.
Giới chiến phí lực phィ lực phィến giám mở của điều tra để xa định mua nhân vụ tài gặp,
tay nạn phà người chiến người xảy ra khá trường suyên tại phí lực phィến,
cúc ra được cố thành từ hông bảy nghĩa hòn đạo lượng nhỏ.